I'm sad Bulgarian clown you remind me of  my mother  oh really you know that I mean you and I  are you know you're pretty close in age  you're funny  it's the Bulgarian clown in you okay she  was marvelous but she was different  exactly like you were yeah I was so  awesome is freaking dogs a hero  mom cut it out  hey mom I gotta go okay I love you oh  all right well okay  ah how are you good to meet you Joe  where were we what's your middle name  Leslie oh my god just like Samuel  Jackson who is that you ever seen any  movie ever  he's the black guy you try that Pizza  sounds delicious  that's it I'm done congratulations San  Francisco  you've ruined pizza faster Hawaiians and  no was white didn't ornament was fined  I think it'll scare the kids the kids  listen in the parents nightmares is that  good test